[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
wie jedes jahr hätte es so aussehen soll
doch es kam anders zum 50 jährigen
jubiläum der art basel findet die
weltweit größte kunstmesse nicht statt
wie es dazu kam jetzt im kultur platz
[Musik]
wie kommen auf dem messeplatz in basel
unser kulturplatz heute ja ich stehe da
wo ich meistens stehe mit der juni mit
mir tausende von besuchern heute würde
die art basel ihre tore öffnen mit viel
pomp wie immer aber der messe platz ist
leer die korona krise hat die größte
kunstmesse der welt in die knie
gezwungen und das ausgerechnet in ihrem
jubiläumsjahr
[Musik]
50 jahre hätte es dieses jahr zu feiern
gegeben statt besten geschlossene türen
jeder sammler klickt und kauft dieses
jahr die kunst für sich allein die art
basel geht nämlich online ja was die
korona krise für die art basel und auch
für den kunstmarkt bedeutet dazu ein
hintergrund von stefan zucker
im letzten dezember war noch alles
bestens für die welt der kunst die sonne
schien die stimmung war angeregt und die
art basel miami im raum die welt der
reichen und schönen
sie war noch in ordnung
die angereisten galeristen waren guter
dinge verkauften gut wenn auch nicht
mehr mit der wucht der jahre zuvor
doch es reichte um satte preise zu
verlangen
[Musik]
zwei bilder 1,2 millionen dollar
wie hoch ist der baselitz 1.200.000 und
der rauschenburg zwei millionen 250.000
die kunst beraterin lisa schiff kämpfte
um die besten deals für ihre potenten
sammer es war wie jedes jahr
leidenschaftlich und herzlich ist echt
ein arsch aber gut in seinem job ich
liebe ihn so ist max ist hinten
das ist eines davon
ein manko dass die skulptur das bild das
bild sie zeigt uns ihre errungenschaft
für mehrere hunderttausend dollar ich
glaube wir haben gerade einen deal
gemacht ihre sammler blieben wie immer
diskret im hintergrund
namen haben wir keine erfahren alles wie
immer oder sogar noch besser für art
basel chef marc spiegler ist miami 2009
10 eine äußerst erfolgreiche ausgabe
die eröffnung war ruhiger was die anzahl
der menschen angeht aber die verkäufe
waren stark es ist perfekt dann etwas
weniger hektisches umfeld aber sehr
umsatzstark
auf der anderen seite des globus bahnte
sich etwas an in hongkong waren die
proteste immer noch stark präsent im
frühling sollte hier die nächste art
basel hongkong stattfinden messedirektor
speaker machte sich ein bild vor ort
[Musik]
ich verbrachte im januar eine woche in
hongkong
ich traf galeristen nicht ratsam live
sah die stadt diese logistisch gut
funktionierte und ich sagte wir können
das tun wir können weitermachen trotz
bedenken die viele leute hatten und dann
in zehn tagen wir die situation mit dem
virus völlig außer kontrolle
zu den protestierenden kann jetzt das
virus dazu und die galeristen fragten
sich zu diesem zeitpunkt besorgt ob man
noch nach hongkong gehen sollte
denn eigentlich noch nie stellt sich ein
gesunder menschenverstand situation ist
derart präsent wie man wird sagen in
englisch dass es schwer vorstellbar dass
man dort basteln konnte innerhalb der
heutigen situation
plötzlich ging es weniger um die kunst
sondern ums geld die galeristen hatten
bereits für ihre messestände bezahlt
sollte die messe abgesagt werden
wer würde ihnen ihre verluste begleichen
als die messe im februar wegen des virus
abgesagt wurde erhielten die galeristen
drei viertel ihrer kosten zurück den
rest behielt die art basel für ihre
verluste
die werke die für mich war mein team
links soden acht monate durch diese
schwierige zeit der politischen unruhen
und so viel wie auch versuchten diese
show durchzuziehen
und so fiel die asiatischen galeristen
noch sammler hinter uns standen damit es
eine gute messe würde
am ende weiß dass wir uns das alles
gehörte die absage der art basel
hongkong läutete das ein was nachher
folgte der fast kompletten stillstand
der globalen kunstwelt
innerhalb eines monats mussten weltweit
90 prozent der galerien schließen die
meisten museen stellten ihren betrieb
ein
ausstellungen gab es plötzlich keine
mehr der kunsthandel kam weltweit zum
erliegen und messechef spiegler saß zu
hause im lockdown viele galerien
kündigten ihren leuten oder in der
schweiz sind sie auf kurzarbeit
in diesem sinn sind galerien wie jedes
andere business auch für den schweizer
künstler raffael hefti war der lockdown
einschneidend er musste sein atelier
fast komplett schließen seine leute nach
hause schicken
ganz hamburg und dort gestoppt war es
einst am anfang als ich sie
diesbezüglich etwas zu weiteren zahlen
wie machen wir das doch eine sparwirkung
sogar woche eine sparen
was braucht man etwas profitiert auch
beim aktionstag zeigt wo er eine
krisensitzung fürs zukommt hefti
produziert mit einem kleinen team
arbeitet aber auch mit ausländischen
industriefirmen zusammen die für ihn
objekte herstellen
das ging jetzt nicht mehr
mir ist merkwürdig länder norwegen
italien wo seine chance mehr wissen wir
wie wichtig es ist nun möglich
außen holen momentan macht er vieles
selber im kleinstformat am küchenherd
anstatt xxl in der fabrik
ja schon
ok kurz
druck
[Musik]
experimente mit metall
später sollen sie wieder industriell
produziert werden für die nächsten
ausstellungen und potenzielle käufer
[Musik]
einer der größten sammler der schweiz
lebt im schlossmauern see in der nähe
von luzern
kein schlechter ort um festzusitzen
musik besitzt eine der wichtigsten
sammlungen chinesischer und asiatischer
kunst weltweit sieg baut in hongkong ein
museum für seine objekte und ein preis
für asiatische kunst der nach ihm
benannt wurde konnte nicht verlieren
werden für aus hier wahnsinnig wichtig
will als äquivalent in europa gc viel
mehr masse als in asien ist das für den
kunsthandel
es ist sehr heftig sie reisen konnte er
nicht mehr von seinem schloss aus
versuchte er so gut wie möglich die welt
der kunst zu unterstützen
als paar sachen kauft wirklich aus dem
grund da die am herzen psychisch das
allgemeine künstler künstlerin wir das
überstehen der b50 und sich ein anderes
projekt zu wischen und sogar ein paar
andere kanäle zu unterstützen
sie konnte es nicht lassen er kaufte
auch kunst die er nur online gesehen
hatte wie diese bilder eines tisches aus
der ming zeit mit den dazugehörigen
negativen die persönlichkeiten die sich
begleitend mit mehrwert bringt weder
meisterfahrer mehr information bessere
information aber konsequent und wenden
das bild im link nur gut ist zum
gelächter größere finanzielle
entscheidung treffen
das ist referierte mit allen anderen
dimension der kamera online kaufen
der traditionelle galerien handel ist
vollkommen eingebrochen
gehandelt wurde während der krise online
oder per telefon
die galerie hauser & wirth musste alle
ihre standorte weltweit schliessen
300 mitarbeiter wurden ins home office
geschickt den schaden will niemand so
recht beziffern
insgesamt sind galerien welt wie die
sind alle zu das wäre glaubhaft als pure
hinterland oder also dass ich absolute
vor allem vielen orten aber ich glaub
mir hat es geht immer chancen operieren
würden wir jetzt gerade eröffnet hand
und waren wir da smarties und schnelle
sportart ein witz war zum galerien
mussten sich was einfallen lassen
so wurde die krise genutzt um mit neuen
verkaufs modellen zu arbeiten so konnte
man werke online kaufen die eben erst
entstanden waren mit lockdown gütesiegel
sozusagen
je populärer der künstler und ihr
knapper das angebot je schneller war die
ware weg das ist sehr ehrlich bleibt das
und immer wird um der wolke zu 600.000
dollar da hat zwölf stücken kommt und
die
sie haben das ist sehr stark komme
müsste das jährlich sich wiederholende
ritual der messe wo sich die akteure der
kunstwelt irgendwo auf der welt treffen
um kunst zu kaufen überdacht werden
die art basel jedenfalls wollte die
mutter messe anfang märz auf keinen fall
absagen höchstens verschieben
zuerst ist fassungslosigkeit dann die
angst es tun zu müssen dann biegt man um
die kurve und zieht das funktioniert
nicht das auch nicht das ist ein risiko
und das auch und an einem gewissen punkt
muss man sagen es macht keinen sinn
später verschob die messe vom juni auf
den september um sie dann ganz absagen
zu müssen ohne messe keine einnahmen für
die art und es geht um die zukunft des
kunsthandels
minute wieder zurück welle zu meiner
messeformat mit der persönlichen
begegnung mit kunst miteinander wo sich
die täter auf bargeld
cbl verträgen die welt ist nicht so
einfach die turniere keine art basel
dieses jahr für die künstlerin claudia
koreck nicht einfach die art ist ein
fester bestandteil ihrer kunst karriere
ihre galerien verkaufen ihre teuersten
werke vor allem während der messe und
das treffen mit den größen der kunstwelt
generiert weiterer aussichten
jetzt wird man ihr werk nur online sehen
und kaufen können
es ist klar
kunst online zu kaufen wie es die
galerien jetzt versuchen mit ihren
online wir in roms wird nie die
physische erfahrung ersetzen kunst zu
sehen
vor allem in der kunst ist der kontakt
wichtig
ich erschaffe massive installation da
ist der kontakt mit den materialien wie
holz oder marmor oder manchmal auch die
größe wie eindrücklich sein kann sehr
wichtig das lässt sich nicht ersetzen
[Musik]
claudia kommt hofft auf nächstes jahr
dann kann sie ihre kunstwerke wieder in
voller größe zeigen
[Musik]
und ich bin es da mit dem direktor der
art basel mit marc spiegler
sie sind der erste direktor der art
basel ohne richtige messe seit 50 jahren
wie fühlt sich das an
ich kann es nicht anders sagen es ist
herzzerreißend heute morgen als ich
ankam in meinem anzug an einem solch
schönen tag
es war zufällig 10 58 genau der moment
wo die türen sich öffnen würden und die
leute gehen zu sehen
das ist niemand da war keine kunst das
war hart jetzt haben sie nichts zu tun
nein das stimmt ganz und gar nicht heute
starten wir die online viewing bruns r
die galerien in basel gewesen wählen und
so werde ich als beispiel in ein paar
stunden auch genau hier stehen um einen
zoom empfang für unsere globalen gönner
zu machen
wir sprechen über zahlen
es geht nicht nur um die auswirkungen
für die art basel sondern auch für
unsere galerien alle galerien die in
dieser woche hierher gekommen wäre
hätten exzellente chancen auf erfolg
gehabt
darum machen wir die online bruns wir
wollten im juni als kommerzieller
höhepunkt des jahres eine gelegenheit
bieten wieder mit sammlern in kontakt zu
treten und im idealfall eine menge werke
zu verkaufen
eines der dinge die mir vor der
einführung der online räume in hongkong
geschlossen hatten war dass jedes
einzelne stück einen preis oder eine
preisspanne haben musste
das ist in der kunstwelt beispiellos
jedenfalls in der messe welt und der
grund dafür war dass ein werk mit einem
kreis viel eher verkauft wird und
letztlich geht es gerade jetzt
vor allem für unsere galerie in dem
kunstwerke zu verkaufen
wenn wir erfolgreich ist braucht es
keine rolle mehr
das ist ganz und gar nicht richtig ich
meine das ist eine überbrückung wir
haben dies nie als ersatz für die messen
der absicht
wir sehen es als etwas was parallel zu
den echten messen laufen kann und ich
denke es ist wichtig zu sehen dass die
zukunft hybrid ist dass diese digitalen
plattformen an die wichtige rolle
spielen
zwischen den zeiten in denen sich die
menschen treffen
auch wenn im moment die jets ruhig sind
die kunstwelt wird nicht provinziell in
einer internationalen welt ist es
wichtig dass man zusammenkommt
angesichts der rolle die die art basel
innerhalb des marktes spielt wird es für
die internationale messe immer einen
platz geben
die mph gruppe der besitzer der art
basel hat schwierigkeiten und braucht
geld werde es die art basel nächstes
jahr noch geben
auf jeden fall die art basel gibt es
nächstes jahr und in absehbarer zukunft
was macht sie so sicher wenn man eine
messe betreibt sind die galerien ihre
klienten als wir am vorletzten
wochenende die absage verschickten
lautete die universelle antwort lasst
uns 2021 stärker zurückkommen die kunden
stehen also hinter der messe und das ist
das wichtigste
solange die grundmiete der messe steht
die show weitergehen
was denken sie wie viele kunst die jungs
wurden dort schon gemacht
ich kann mir das nicht einmal
ansatzweise vorstellen
ich bin sicher es gab nicht in denen
kunstwerke im wert von 100 millionen
dollar bei cocktails verkauft wurden
waren genau deshalb brauchen wir diese
art von veranstaltung um uns zusammen zu
bringen weil man sieht sehr viel man
denkt wie nach aber es ist von angesicht
zu angesicht wo die dinge passieren
denkst du
[Musik]
von face to face hinein in die digitale
art basel
[Musik]
ab freitag zugänglich nicht nur für
fachpublikum sondern für alle
man kann herumstöbern preise vergleichen
von 2000 kunstwerken in 230 galerien
interviews mit künstlerinnen
diskussionen alles online und alles ohne
dass spezielle flair der kunstwelt
man ist ganz schön einsam auf dieser
digitalen art den virtuellen raum haben
wir nun erkundet
[Musik]
aber der physische interessiert uns
natürlich auch
[Musik]
und da ist die art basel selbst dieses
jahr nicht gibt wollen wir wissen wie es
aussieht an einem hotspot wo sich sonst
wohl eh der internationalen kunstwelt
ein stelldichein gibt
in der bar des hotels trois dort bin ich
mit der direktorin tanja wegmann
verabredet
eigentlich wäre jetzt da wirklich bei
der anprobe weniger im haus überhaupt
schafft von jahr ist es still
welche konsequenzen hat absage für die
größte kunst auf ihres hus also wir uns
ist ein trauriger moment ruhige woche
es ist eigentlich nach stefans nach der
immer das highlight in basel und wie sie
sagen es war jetzt du schon morgen
früher war eigentlich sehr viele andere
große masse bastelt oder mach ich
bereits abgesprungen ist dermaßen
standorte internationale von basel ist
der bald vergangenheit das system also
ich habe hoffnung dass es nach stahl
wieder gut ich glaube dass ihr eure
genre wo mir ali vor allem hoteliers in
der schweiz der vorliege werde
und ich danke mir hoffe zunächst ihr
viele events inflation verschoben und
das gut wie viele positive menschen
jetzt werde das heute sehr gern in
beschlag künstlerinnen und künstler
normale winter statt dieter roth war
haben wir schon miterlebt andere
installationen bei ihnen impulse nach
sind sie verband normale wie es mit dem
kunstbetrieb sehr sehr sie haben jetzt
rothbauer gesprochen
wir haben aber in den letzten jahren
aber toll über vor wo sehr an mit
künstlern zusammen schafft und sie habe
in der business und investiere das ist
bauer vom minister und du wirst jetzt
natürlich in der lobby war sehr viel los
und darüber was ich mir vorstelle ich
eine woche im jahr ist energie hörer in
dem haus als lehrer war von einer
kunststoff das ganze haus greift grenzt
das beschrieben wie das ist lange wochen
es ist will intensivwoche wir haben
extrem viele winzer im huus sehr viel
künstlerische war die dauer ihres
business machen name viele kollegen
wurden und das bild mit stelle das will
ich den globe ihr ja immer sehr speziell
man kann sich vorstellen dass
versteinerung schon lange große grund
stil gemacht oder sich so ich mein
zimmer schon mit kunst verbundes sie zu
unserer historie gehört natürlich auch
die bieter sowohl durch schon mal
übernachtet hätte es geht ein tolles
bild von ihm wonach überträgt und nacht
auf dem balkon herzlich
[Musik]
nicht nur die art basel ist dieses jahr
abgesagt sondern auch die dazugehörende
designmesse wurde annulliert
das bringt uns zu einer der grössten
designerinnen des frühen zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts eileen gray sie war ihrer
zeit weit voraus und aus architekten
machte sie sogar le corbusier konkurrenz
dieser reagierte mit eifersucht auf
ihrem meisterwerk ein aufsehenerregendes
haus in südfrankreich
nun ist dieses buch erschienen ein edel
comic auf französisch eileen gray matter
soleil und diese geschichte über das
haus unter der sonne
er weist alle in grey noch einmal später
ihre ein haus wie ein schiff ein traum
in weiß mit blick aufs meer
doch eileen grays architektonischer wurf
in rot grün gleich gegenüber von monaco
erlebt beinahe schiffbruch
es ist eine geschichte von liebe verrat
missbrauch tod nun auf französisch
einfühlsam erzählt von der illustratorin
sascha tisch of ska unter architektin
charlotte altäre party in zürich
arbeitet und sich für frauen in der
architektur engagiert ich sah in dieser
geschichte eine solch dramatische
energie dass sich zuerst eine oper
daraus machen wollte es war alles da was
es dazu braucht
drama die bösen die guten eine
unglaubliche geschichte rund um die
architektur
ich bin nicht sehr musikalisch veranlagt
und habe dann an einen film gedacht
bis mir schließlich die idee kam einen
comic zu machen
die protagonisten das haus e 10 27 und
seine erbauerin eileen gray außerdem ihr
lebenspartner schon bardot wie sie der
rumänische architekt und autor sowie der
schweizer le corbusier
ihm wurde grace haus fälschlicherweise
zugeschrieben
er hinterließ darin auch unübersehbare
spuren
eileen gray geboren 1878 stammt aus
einer irisch schottischen adelsfamilie
sie studiert in london malerei zieht
nach paris kreiert ultramoderne teppiche
und möbel und eröffnet 1922 eine
boutique unter dem namen john diese ein
unternehmen zu gründen ist mutig genug
da kann es nicht schaden ein männliches
pseudonym zu nehmen um sich das leben
einfacher zu machen
eileen gray gehört zur pariser
avantgarde ihre große liebe
die extravagante chansonsängerin dann ja
und sie lernt sie kennen
er ist es der grey ermutigt ein
liebesnest für sie beide zu bauen
ich weiß nicht einmal was das ist große
architektur lasse ich ja genau so gut
wie gordon kam schon john gobbi sie ist
ein genie ich bin innenarchitekten alles
was wir brauchen ist deine vision nach
corbusiers grundsätzen entwirft gray e10
27 geht aber weiter als der vater der
modernen setzt mit ihren ideen neue
maßstäbe ihr haus soll die sinne
ansprechen keine wohnmaschine sein
die introvertierte zuweilen auf großen
der autodidaktin will ein
gesamtkunstwerk schaffen
sie war sehr kritisch mit sich selbst
aber auch sehr produktiv sie hat mit
lackarbeiten angefangen teppich
entworfene möbel design um dann als
architektin zu arbeiten
sie war sehr kreativ kritisch und
cholerisch anscheinend 19 29 beziehen
eileen und schon endlich ihre
sommerresidenz doch schon bald zerbricht
die beziehung aline zieht aus überlässt
song das house of the seas freund luc
carl bis sie ist nun oft zu besuch
er ist besessen von grace werk und
offensichtlich in seiner eitelkeit
verletzt
19 38 bemalt er nackt in einem charme
und respektlosen akt die schlicht
gestalteten wände erwerben kann er die
villa nicht aber er kann markieren baut
nebenan die schüchterne gray lässt es
geschehen
eileen gray hat vor ihrem tod ihr ganzes
archiv verbrannt was unsere arbeit sehr
erschwert hat jemand hätte ihr die
bedeutung ihrer arbeit klar machen und
ihr selbstvertrauen geben müssen
die werke von architektinnen ins
rampenlicht rücken
dazu soll diese kunstvoll gestaltete
omas beitragen
10 27 verlotterte später zu sehen
seit jahren renoviert der verein gab
modernen das haus inklusive malereien
übrigens le corbusier ertrank 1965
direkt unterhalb von grace meisterwerk
im meer
[Musik]
dass solche reise nach basel nächste
woche da fahren wir aufs land und
treffen einen der zelebriert das
landleben auf fast schon unverschämte
art und weise den popsänger marc
trauffer gleich jetzt folgt ihr die
britische tv serie bodyguard kommen sie
gut durch die woche
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
fristlos